I don't want to alarm you Donald Trump
jr. but we just found out John Schnatter
was he was fabricating he did not
actually eat 40 full pizzas in 30 days
this could be jarring I know it's early
in the morning like I don't know if you
want to deal with this right now
that's the Papa John's guy yeah John's
yeah he didn't actually have he said he
test he's going back on that he tested
40 pizzas he didn't actually eat the
entire pizzas you know if they if Trump
said that they didn't page him for it
[Laughter]
thirty-nine point seven five pizzas it
would be over where the problem is he
said it to the Russians yesterday you
posted it was on your Instagram and it
was your dad was uh like thanking you
guys the family I think I'm not sure
where that was but was really it was
nice he was like getting my family and
my my son's in my way and it was like
that was a really nice side of him that
I don't see that and like I like that
side of him a lot the family side yeah I
do too I think he's an old-school guy I
mean you know construction building you
know I think he doesn't he doesn't
really like showing sort of the other
side it's there and you sort of see it
and sometimes you see it in the
reactions or even the stories years
later from other people who he sort of
touched in a way that they wouldn't
expect you know I don't mean like Joe
Biden I mean like you know did something
you know unusually nice for but yeah
it's not a side he likes to shoot show
that much and yeah sometimes I wish he
actually would because it is there it is
real is that from being in business and
all of a sudden like in business
weakness or certain things are
interpreted as like hey man I really
think it is I think you know it's it's
that I think it's the nature of sort of
you know his father was sort of the same
way he was like you know great guy
stupid but like you know just a very
tough sort of Germanic guy you know
became the man of the house at you know
12 years old and it was like now we're
in charge so it was it was just that
sort of drive and work and everything
else and there so I think it's just you
know partially that and so ya know I
think when he shows it it's pretty
amazing cuz it we see a lot of it but it
I was like you should like to highlight
why would I I like that but you know
it's just different it's a nice side
that I watch the videography side of it
was
I didn't was that from the White House I
think it was the White House I think it
was sort of after all of that he just
sort of was like hey you know I really
just want to say sorry to my family for
putting him through all of you know you
know he knew that politics would be
rough I think I spoke to you guys last
time when I was just in here unlike my
book tour yeah you know talking about it
like when he looked at me in the
elevator and you know as he's going down
to announce you know back in like June
of 15 and it was like now we find out
who our real friends are
you know and you know he's not gonna do
say something all you know overtly
profound or anybody was just he's just
such a realist that way and it was sort
of cool to see because a it meant you
know he's sort of a student of life like
he gets it he understands the real world
and and what that's all about and it
seems like in 2020 you don't actually
live in the real world you sort of live
in this like pretend world but it's not
real right you write like it's a bubble
or you have to be this way and you can't
think that and yeah you know he sort of
gets it but was what was cooler for me
about him and why now when he's doing
this job was he got it he knew how rough
it was gonna be and he did it anyway
yeah you know I mean like he didn't need
this job he didn't need to go in and
their dad you know he I don't know if we
knew him quite as brutal or vicious as
it's been do you think he expected to
win when he first first signed up when
he first went down that escalator shot
he announced he's running and everybody
was like oh this is kind of a goof he's
threatened to do this before but the
celebrity is now saying he's gonna run
do you think at that point or even by
the first debate that he really thought
I might be the president you know I
don't know I mean listen I don't think
he's gonna do anything where he thinks
he's gonna get blown out you know I mean
like I think he sort of assess the
fields you know the strengths the
weaknesses and and said yeah I think I
can bring something different and you
know I think he's a little different as
a politician obviously but also even as
a business guy approaching it right if
you you know say you know you did a
Bloomberg compared to you well both
business guys but like it's a little
different for Trump because you know
being a real estate guy being a builder
versus a financial services guy he's
actually interacted with real people
with real Americans and I think that's
why he was sort of able to rely
even though on paper you'd say there's
no way that this guy could have an
understanding of sort of blue-collar
America right yeah because he spent time
on job sites he walked around it he
spoke to those guys not just you know
people behind a computer what was the
first indication you had cuz that's a
good question do you think using when
and when it starts happening you're
probably okay he my what was the first
thing that happened we like Jesus
actually really win like what was the
first indication you had that like this
is going way better than anybody thinks
debate number one in the Republican
primary you know remember when they did
the thing where it's like well raise
your hand you know if you will not
blindly support like a sheep whoever the
candidate is regardless of what they say
about you over the next six months and
everyone's like oh yeah well we'll
obviously do that regardless so he's
like yeah you know puts his hand up like
yeah I'm not a lemming anyone you know
and I remember that shot he's the only
person raising his hand and you just
kind of shrug his shoulders
I miss it of when you look at the
Democrat feel be like universal health
care you're just gonna pay for you know
or you're gonna fund health care for all
illegal immigrants like just raise your
head oh well we're gonna do that like
Americans don't get that but you're
gonna do it for illegals like you know
it was that because I go you don't he's
not a sheep and you know our politicians
have been too afraid to take on real
issues they just sort of go blindly by
whatever a survey says that minute
rather than making an intelligent
decision and when I saw that I go
there's something here cuz people are
fed up of just you know the same old
same old and you you make promises and
you don't actually do anything and
there's no accountability and you know
that's just sort of the way the game has
been played for far too long
well you look even on the Democrat side
we talked about this like the guys in
the in the front or Bernie Pete Budaj
and maybe eight Amy Klobuchar like
they're all different than Biden and
it's almost like even on that side of it
you have people are just tired of the
same thing and Bernie's a politician
Bernie's you know Bernie's a politician
but he actually has a real following
right yeah meaning mayor Pete didn't
have a following before this it's like
you know it come on give me a break like
there are people we sit there dong I
like Bernie I'm not blindly
voting for a party I'm not just voting
for not Trump I actually like Bernie
correct I mean and so you know and you
could see the DNC sort of doing whatever
they can to try to screw Bernie I mean
yeah but I was like hey keep going guys
you know their instincts are so good the
last time they rigged a primary they
gave us Hillary Clinton which was
honestly I was like thank God like a you
guys do your thing please because
whatever you do to screw Bernie's gonna
help us and that's the reality I mean
you know every you know the the
political overlords think they know
better but you know the thing I've
learned over the last four years and you
know starting during the campaign and
just spending so much time on the ground
and in like real places you know not
like our bubble in New York City here
and you say you know people actually
understand what's going on
much better than anyone wants to give
them credit for I mean they actually get
it they are there are people that are
out there that you know understand this
and everyone sort of wants to treat them
as though no no they don't know anything
we know better we're gonna force-feed
them what they must want yeah and it's
not working they get it Nancy plot like
I we talked about this - Nancy Pelosi
we're like Oh see not showing up or
Pelosi ripping up the page you see was a
guy from Ohio who was like I left the
State of the Union I wish they did some
sort of polling you know beforehand and
was like oh this is how to get a
reaction I mean you saw the video of
like Nancy Pelosi like pre ripping the
speech like this wasn't you know like I
wasn't you got to give Trump credit for
like he's pretty good on the fly yeah
you know I mean he comes up like he
doesn't nothing he's ever done it's like
pre orchestrated it's like me came up
with it he said it whether you're like
it or not he's just gonna say it that's
what he thinks you know you see the
video of her like minutes before like
pre ripping the speech just so she
doesn't have like a fail on TV of like
and not being able to rip the rip pages
of paper like you know and it was so
contrived and I mean you saw her yeah I
got to lead yet another outrage cycle
last week because you know that video
that my father posted of you know you
highlighted you know the
african-american child what you know who
got like her scholarship of a school
choice thing then you had the war
veteran the Tuskegee Airmen the fur
african-american fighter pilot how usual
you know I did I went to a friend of
mine one of the kids from turning-point
USA Bennie Johnson I was like he's
really good with sort of the video stuff
I go I got an idea
I want you to show my father
highlighting each of these people and
then rip their dreams up cuz that's what
that was I mean it was it was it
incredibly sort of emotional speech it
was uncharacteristically trumping that
he did highlight some of you know these
great American stories and then it's
just it flashed us to her ripping it up
each time ripping it up each time I mean
she literally went to Facebook to try to
get them to ban the video and it wasn't
like we doctored a video right but
that's just like this is what she
actually did these are the American
dream she's actually ripping up and I
say like hey weather or a public under a
Democrat like if you're a deaf one thing
that in the last three and a half years
they've actually tried to do like it's
not like Trump has blocked Democrats
from doing anything they've done nothing
they've not proposed anything they've
not gone forward with anything you know
the reality is he's still gotten things
done I mean he's gotten us MCA done he
renegotiated NAFTA for the American
worker I mean he got a trade deal done
with China you know despite you know
being sort of under the gun in
impeachment I imagine like if they
worked with him and the other side
didn't see sort of you know these
attacks on the president you could
probably make the deal even better did
you like that that she tried to get that
video banned because I feel like you
more so than most people in your
position you love to troll which I don't
think is a bad thing I saw you post the
thing about Mitt Romney and his G the
reality is I like to have some fun you
know I I don't you know it sort of from
the conservative side where everyone was
for decades has just been such a stiff
yeah well I have to have the formal
response on how to deal with the shut up
you got a hit back yeah and I think you
know Trump has shown you know at least
one side that you can fight and I sort
of feel for decades
you know Republicans have played t-ball
while Democrats have played hardball and
played that game really well and there's
nothing they won't do no one they won't
destroy I mean look at what they try to
do to break Cavanaugh who like literally
before this the only pictures I'd ever
seen of Brett Kavanaugh is him like at a
soup kitchen on a Sunday like so
you know people food like yeah they
would take his life his career just
destroy it for political gain I mean it
was so serious such a serious act you
know cuz he was obviously a gang wrist
right you know that Dianne Feinstein sat
on the accusations in her office for
three months he was such a real threat
to society that they sat on it for three
months till his confirmation hearing you
know what they tried to do to the
Covington Catholic kids you know that
kid did nothing oh he showed much more
restraint than probably anyone we know
would have you know when being
antagonized and agitated but but what
about that sustains immediate what about
that evil stare he had it was you know
it was very varied it was a hateful
stare when someone's in your face like
you know clapping and yelling and then
you had the other groups do it saying
all the black lights who are yelling
anti-gay stuff and racist stuff at them
you know but that got no coverage but
you know to watch the DNC and the
mainstream media just literally say
we're gonna take that kid's life and
we're gonna ruin it for a narrative man
it you know so I like that you know you
have someone now who's just willing to
push back not just take the [ __ ] and
be like okay well we're gonna be you
know you can only turn the cheek so many
other it's so many times before you
start looking like a smug how many time
on to it because my I think the thing I
agree with your dad the most on and the
most consistent the most hundred-percent
is the press because they're so
completely one-way and unfair what was
the first thing that you know that he
noticed were they're like oh they're
gonna paint this the way they want to
paint like what was the first indication
that this was not going to be like as
fair as you'd like it to me honestly
like the list goes on and on I but it
was like three chapters of my book you
know those are great examples just I
mean I like using the Covington Catholic
thing cuz it's like it was it was sort
of like woke media's like Holy Grail
right it was a young white male from the
south who happened to be religion
religious like who we could ruin this
kid's life cuz he's everything we hate
like what
why like but he just checked off so many
boxes of why we're going to destroy it
you know he wasn't some you know I don't
know you know whatever it was he he was
just the guy that this is perfect for
them the story was too good to me are
the other one honestly the justice
Millette thing yeah I mean I think we
talked about it when I was in on the
book tours I mentioned it here and there
on social media yeah yeah yeah
pah-pah-pah my god there's Don sweating
a little bit I was the first guy I think
okay maybe there was others they called
it out in comedy but I was the first guy
maybe let's call it in business and or
in politics maybe like the first guy was
something to lose they can't just be
like well I'm just a comedian it but you
know I was the first guy that got you
know cancelled on Instagram for being
like
okay guys like I see the outrage I see
that it's on Ellen you know every show
and every CNN and MSNBC and it was a 40
and I'm like I don't know guys like if
someone really did this fry him right
okay I've said first thing all right if
but like really like this guy who's
making you know millions as an actor got
really hungry at 2:00 a.m. and on the
coldest night of the year in Chicago and
I built a building in Chicago I've spent
lots of time like it gets damn cold
uh-huh decided to go to Subway like I
don't know today see you today you're
probably ordering seamless so I started
asking these questions I'd like your
problems starting with like okay let's
just start with Subway it's great you
know really like you're gonna go out at
minus 14 or whatever it was at 2:00 a.m.
to get us up like your order seamless
that's what you do like you're pretty
famous Don jr. at 2:00 a.m. on a very
cold night I'm just dealing with would
you walk to a sub well now I would nine
something else to eat a home I can
either you know and then it was like
okay so yeah two guys white guys white
supremacists problem get in in Mogga
hats oh yeah in downtown Chicago hmm
also on the coldest night of the year
like that's who I am yeah 2:00 a.m. and
and by the way and they didn't get shot
they managed to live long enough to find
Jesse Smollett because they know who
Jesse Smollett is because obviously
Empire has a huge audience of white
supremacists yes you know I mean you
know they obviously know who this guy is
and they were taking a chance and he'd
be out at 2:00 in the morning on the
coldest night of the year going into
subway they were it's so much foresight
huh
that they decided to bring a twine noose
yes you know breaking strength of about
two pounds and a bucket of bleach and
I'm just saying man trust me I get it
like I was like I I know that I could
this could go so wrong for me yeah if
I'm wrong but I'm saying can
any reasonable person meaning if it
wasn't 2019 you know and you went back
to a reasonable time in history yeah
would you look at this fact set and be
like oh yeah no-brainer like this
definitely happened or would you be like
give me a freakin break you like you'd
call [ __ ] so fast and so I did and I
was like I just don't see this hat and
then all of a sudden well the cops are
saying that he won't give us the phone
and then he's saying he's upset that
they're actually investigating at this
heart I'm saying wait a minute so you
telling me he wanted the best of both
worlds he wanted them to actually not
investigate so then he could [ __ ] and
moan and say oh they didn't even look at
you know this case of obvious white
supremacy and yeah you know and then you
see the connection with the DA and the
Obamas and they're not gonna pursue it
on Fox yeah I'm saying oh my god like
this is insane but meanwhile Instagram
is doing this all these like left-wing
things Donald Trump jr. spreading racist
conspiracy I wasn't spreading anything I
asked a frickin question do you know
when that first happened my first day
did we get instincts as people you see
something and you're like that doesn't
feel a physic [ __ ] and but it's like
it's hard to come right out and say
immediately cuz you like God if this guy
did get attacked today
yeah my side and you get it wrong it's
over you finished Roseanne had a stupid
tweet her career is over the other guy's
like he'll get a starring role on his
next show despite the fact that he
literally tried to create a race war try
to better you know try it no hits right
what do you imagine they to caught you
know two young white kids that maybe fit
that description imagine they did that
just happen to be in the area
like you know extreme coincidence but it
happens right especially a bucket of
bleach yeah cuz that's how ridiculous
the story was but like imagine they felt
like someone like that they would have
destroyed these people and he wouldn't
have come out and said I was just
kidding like you know that's some scary
[ __ ] and that it's happening and that
this is a mainstream guy who's out there
with all these left-wing politicians and
he's hanging out with the Obamas and
he's like you know what this is how I'm
gonna get more money in my next thing
because I'm gonna make myself the victim
I'm not saying that racism isn't a real
problem okay like it is it's just not
the answer to every problem that every
person on the left has that you well you
know that doesn't add up that is math
obviously racist we make stop
it's the accusations enough does it
disservice to those who are actually
affected by now you hear racist and
you're like okay like roll your eyes
move on like it's probably [ __ ] and
it's not always [ __ ] it's just when
you use it as sort of the easy button of
left-wing politics like I have no answer
for that therefore racist it doesn't
work anymore we were talking about the
primaries I want to know if you guys
have have you spoken to the Bush family
at all because the primaries were brutal
your dad brought it to a whole nother
level also the most entertaining primary
season of all time but I found it like
and we've talked about it on the show
astounding that there was basically an
implicit everybody falls in line for the
most part like it was implied that Ted
Cruz's dad may have had something to do
with the assassination of dick JFK Ted
Cruz has fallen in line watching
everybody fall in line but there was
something so viscerally humiliating
about what happened to Jeb Bush I feel
like that one that he that has not
forgiven I've been friends with his son
and I agree with that I mean I did jeb
has not I mean I actually you know was
helping his son and stuff like that but
then I'd be like literally doing a
fundraiser for his son like helping him
out in endorsed um you know he'd said we
don't sort thank you notes and my father
endorsed your George P the Jeb son you
know but then it was like you know Jeb
would come out and do this I go hey Jeb
you know I wish you had this much of a
backbone when you actually were in
politics like everything everyone's it's
sort of like the internet right
everyone's a badass like after the fact
and so you know I think for the most
part you know they've been fine and you
know like I said George he's been you
know been good to us and decent to us
but like you know Jeb just can't let it
go though I was like you know finally I
just put out one of these tweets that
sort of I haven't heard much since then
which was just like you know you know to
the effect of you know hey wish you
would have done something then like you
know dot the reality
this though you career politicians you
spent your whole life doing this in
Donald Trump within two weeks stepped
into a game with zero experience and
destroyed your life's work that's what I
pulled it away from under you because
you guys didn't have the guts to
actually do the things you're pretending
to have the guts to do now like if only
you fought the Democrats as hard as you
did the Republican nominee maybe you
wouldn't be in this position maybe you
wouldn't need a trump to step up and say
okay it's time to put the big-boy pants
on and like actually do something what
did he do that took them so that's
doesn't ask you what did he do that took
them so off-guard because none of them
knew how to deal with him well he didn't
how to deal with him none of them knew
what to do he has a personality listen
whether you know whether you like
everything that he says or not or
whatever it is like you know you can
look at the things he says I say okay
fine like the media does a great job of
like pretending Trump isn't joking when
he's joking right you know you see it in
print and you're like wow that's pretty
bad then you see the video and it's like
oh oh he's I mean you know I remember
when they're like hey oh my god you're
CNN Donald Trump asked the Russians to
look into Hillary angle really like wow
when well yesterday I go well where you
mean in Michigan yeah and Michigan well
at the rally in front of 25,000 like I
mean he's having fun he's doing shtick
you know he's doing that thing and it's
like they try to take it so seriously
that they've done themselves such a
disservice because every any reasonable
individual watching knows when he's
kidding and went and when he's not it's
also it's also they try to pretend that
he's being serious when he's kidding
that they just sort of undercut their
whole argument you know it's also
difficult I think for career politicians
in a debate setting when like Jeb Bush
is like well my brother kept America
safe and your dad kind of implies that
well he was you know somewhat
responsible for 9/11 that like Jeb is
sitting there going like what the [ __ ]
just happened here how I supposed to
come back you miss my daddy he also
understands branding right I mean he can
pick out sort of someone's flaws and
someone's weaknesses better than any
human being alive and like brand you on
the spot in a like Jeb as many Lennard
low-energy
you know Jeb was lower
and like he said it on the debate and
literally two days later you see Jeb
running a commercial in like New
Hampshire you know for the primary of
him like the Chris Farley like you know
what he's doing the rut like trying to
be high-energy it's like you see that he
picked that his weakness he nailed it
and like the kid like maneuver and when
you respond to that like when you
respond to the nickname so quickly and
literally like when you want to show
look how high-energy I am you're never
gonna shake it that's what you know we
got it was over and so like then the
second debate you know whatever I maybe
a second or third debate of the primary
you could see sort of Jeb like trying to
have high energy trying to push back and
and like rather than just engage in the
fight my dad was just like hey Jeb
that's great good came in with this plan
you don't even like everyone's got a
plan till he get punched in the face
right like they came in with this plan
and Donald Trump just sort of flipped
the script on I mean it was like yeah
Jed you know I remember when you were
here in the middle of the stage you're
about to fall off like you know and it
was over you can't get sensitive too
though I feel like he's very sensitive
when that picture came out of him the
other day whereas his hair was getting
blown back and you can kind of see the
orange outline around his face yeah I
didn't actually see the reaction - I've
been on the road so much but like the
reality is ya don't listen he does at
times but I also think that you know if
there's someone who's capable of
actually making fun of himself
it's Trump my husband roasted it's funny
people heated a sense of humor he's been
roasted twice he got roasted on Comedy
Central and he got roasted by the Friars
Club like I don't think any other
candidate on that super gross has been
attacked by comedians twice and sathru
made a lifetime of being like when he
was a celebrity you know and I mean
people but it was different than then it
was almost like hey fine you can do that
it's in good spirits like here it's
literally just vicious it's it's like it
is a lot different right I mean if you
look at what they did to him if you look
you know as we said like hunter Biden is
totally off limits you can't touch the
50 year old son of the vice president of
Canada you can't talk about him and
making millions from Ukraine and but
like a bear in trumpet fort
totally fair game you know nummies you
can go after him or you want to defend
them towards Ivanka like that like you
don't have to agree with her but like
some of the venom coming towards her
from people in showbiz is it's like if
you spoke that way about any other
candidate if you said if you put Ivanka
and Chelsea Clinton in a room together
and you and you said those things about
Chelsea like it'd be over but like hey
you know you couldn't even really like
there was not a and again I'm from New
York right so it's like there was not a
New York like leftist like
celebrity-type that three and a half
years ago didn't want their daughter to
turn out like Ivanka okay she was at all
of those parties she was the guest of
honor from all of these people and then
all of a sudden it's like now
oh no she's Tara like give me a break
guys like you know stop
does it ever does it ever do you think
it ever bothers your dad like that like
like the fact that like yeah I know
that's part of the game but it ever
moments where it's like you think it'll
actually gets to him like man I can't
believe these people just kind of now
they dislike me and I was friends with
them at one point you know like I said
when he looked at me and said you know
now we find out who our real friends are
I think he got it like you know the
reality is not that many people have
that much resolve most people are sheep
they don't want to they're not gonna
buck the trends they don't want to take
that venom and so they fall in line and
you know that line and in in this world
where we live here do York or whatever
it's like well you know if you're not on
the Left you're you're crazy like the
reality is he didn't need this job but
he did it for the other Americans that
aren't those people so you know while he
was a part of that scene and maybe
enjoyed some of it like you know I think
the reality is I've been calling him
sort of the blue-collar billionaire for
25 years I used to get [ __ ] for calling
him that cuz they were like oh yeah well
goodie like okay now you see it he does
seem though that he really values
loyalty because it seems like that's the
thing that gets him right like when he
feels like somebody has betrayed him or
somebody goes against him in this world
right that somebody was it was with him
while he was the president either goes
against him or there's leaks in the
White House or whatever it is that's
when you see him going on those rampages
on Twitter that's when you see him get
pissed off I think listen he's an
old-school guy that way I mean he values
those kind of things that you know in in
this day and age don't mean as much to
as many people like I mean he's sort of
you know values the the meaning of a
handshake in the old-school world not
just like a you know today we're just ok
shake hands and then go do whatever you
want let the lawyers break
up and I mean he's sort of old-school
that way so it you know he does it
probably does bother him more than it
does most when when someone does betray
your trust and Roger stone to that had
this you died tweeted and for
prosecutors quit and then it turns out
one of the people on the jury liked it
turned out they had like kind of mocked
Rogers arrest they don't like your
father they don't know this was a
Democrat that ran for Congress on a
anti-trump like and he ends up on the
jury and no one says anything and then
Roger stone gets nine years now I'm not
saying what he did was right I don't
even I think the reality is Roger stone
wasn't involved that I campaign at all I
get her they try to make them out so
they could just hurt someone close to
Trump world a guy I didn't even saw
Roger stone on our campaign I don't
think you're right but like sorta I feel
like Roger stones one of those guys I
was trying desperately to be relevant so
he was in a dark room throwing darts and
he actually hit something and then they
called him in then he was stupid to lie
about it but like you know pretending
that you know these prosecutors are
these these are just humble public
servants who are they're not there these
are partisan hacks in so many cases I
mean that's the problem with DC it's
filled with these people it's sort of
like the whistleblower right the
whistleblower there was that one of the
lead outrage cycles was I apparently
outed the whistleblower which was
interesting because all I believe that's
right remember this one yep you know
because I outed him because i retweeted
an article that had his name in the
title of the article it was sitting on
Drudge Report for four days I'm like
what do you mean I outed him it's
literally in like mainstream print like
what it like on the largest news you
know website of the world for four days
like I didn't and I'm like wait a minute
it's not that I outed him it was that
now that you see his name like regular
people not the DC elite who all knew who
it is like let's stop pretending that
this is a secret guys come on give me a
frickin break but now that you know who
he is regular people can do a little
Google search and be like oh oh he's a
protege of Susan Rice oh oh he's buddies
with McCabe who like you know lied to
Congress but did not get in trouble for
it because he's on their team right oh
oh wow this isn't good he's the guy
that's in the photograph you know with
the whole Obama Susan Rice team crying
all black in front of the Oval Office
the day after my father won the
nomination oh yo here's Joe Biden's
guest at the state dinner hey you know
who that's not so good you know this guy
isn't you know the humble public servant
who's dedicated his leg give me a break
guys
the partisan hack and that's all he is
you know and there's a lot of them in DC
I'm not saying there aren't others on
the on this side but you know on the
Republican side but like the left is
seem to dominate this world and they've
done a good job in trenching them and
and they will do whatever they can to
stop someone who's a threat okay to that
you know sort of deep state you know
elite political unit frankly on both
sides and Trump is that I mean he came
in from the outside he's blowing these
things up he's calling this [ __ ] out and
like this is a an existential threat to
their existence
this way they've created these little
fiefdom Xand they have total power and
they can get away with anything like I
said half the people on the other side
have literally lied to Congress look at
the faceless stuff look at what Comey
did and he runs around in the media oh I
know this guy's great it's like he's
literally leaking classified stuff too
then he lies about it and then when they
catch him lying about it sit the the
headline is written incorrectly so that
they could say oh this is incorrect we
like it's a freaking joke the New York
Times changed a headline like there was
something they said it was it was
trumped I like says something in his
message and it wasn't a bad headline and
they change they got crap they got
canceled by their own readership because
it wasn't against Trump enough and
that's the point there's no more
pretense of objectivity right
no one's pretending that hey we're just
reporting the news anymore right
al-baghdadi right the founder and leader
of Isis okay the guy that was you know
Osama bin Laden's right-hand man are you
pro or anti I'm a huge fan okay of where
he is now my father kills him right
since you know Conan down the tunnel the
guy blows himself up great this is
something that every reasonable American
should be able to agree is a good thing
for the world I mean this is a guy you
think the media would be outraged who
litter
put people in cages douse them with
gasoline and lit them on fire drown them
those around them he threw gay guys off
buildings you know this is not a good
guy right the Washington Post I don't
mean like Fox or some you know left-wing
rag that you know you can't you know the
Washington Post headline his obituary
and austere religious scholar like this
is some guy praying in a cave and he's a
wonderful guy like he's just a little
misunderstood it really was psychotic if
they had that they changed that to I
think they oppression into changing that
yeah but like you know to like that was
their first thought not this guy is a
terrible person who killed me you know
like we're gonna make him good because
Trump got him
you know it's sick guys like no there's
no way of looking at that reasonably and
saying okay this was an error
you know they changed the title on that
one three different times and again if
it's a title that's even remotely fair
they get cancelled by the left and so
they have to change it to make it worse
about Trump and half the time you see
these titles and it's like man that's
pretty rough yeah then you read the
article be like oh that's not so bad
like the title and that's you know
partially Twitter's fault I mean we live
in a world of 280 characters or less
honestly no one plays in that game
better than perhaps you know me or my
father there at this point at least from
you know our side of the table but like
yeah you adapt to it yeah you have to
you know so you know and again that's
why the book was sort of fun to write
because it's like wow I can actually go
long-form on this like I can rail
against you know communism and socialism
as someone who lived through some of
that you know that's the outrage cycle
today I said it on Hannity last night
right you know talking about like my
mother escaped communism like I actually
have experience with this you know I was
I saw pictures of my parents wedding and
my grandfather is the only one there I'm
like where's my grandmother's like well
they wouldn't let her out of the country
with me they let me out to walk my
daughter down the aisle but they
wouldn't let my wife come with me
because honestly if you got a chance to
get out you're not coming back right so
my god that's weird that's sort of an
interesting system so he took me over
there
every year from the age of five and like
I've waited in those bread lines and
that's what they're outraged about today
he didn't do that he was in Prague in
something like there was no Bohemian
Prague back in the day but I wasn't I
was in a literally a factory town four
hour drive three and a half four hour
drive east of Prague like I wasn't in
like you know some beautiful metropolis
like you know my grandma my father
grandfather was an electrician you know
in communist Czechoslovakia my
grandmother was like a telephone
operator like you know it wasn't like I
was getting some sort of royal treatment
when I was over there like you're a blue
collar billionaire yeah I was well
perhaps right but like I experienced
that stuff growing up and they were like
you got to see this so when I see sort
of the rise of socialism and communism
on the other side yeah I get it right
it's a scary thing to you because you've
seen what the that looks like as an
extreme a hundred percent but more
importantly like I understand that in
2020 Jim I'm not allowed to have an
opinion you know I'm a white guy who
from a rich family who's obviously you
know but give it everything I kept I get
you I can't voice that opinion I'm not
allowed to have it whatever it is is
diminished greatly even if I'm right you
know so they try to do that Don sits but
like the reality is I have sort of an
interesting story and that I've seen
this stuff I've been there you know I
spent six eight week yeah four to six
weeks every summer there for my entire
like childhood yeah like I get it yeah
and what do you think I'm gonna go back
to Roger stone for a second I'm sure you
obviously you don't know right but if
you had to guess do you think your dad's
gonna eventually pardon him
I honestly I don't know I mean I you
know Roger stone was running around you
know saying that I'm going to be
indicted again
Roger stones one of those guys looking
for attention right okay he'd do it
every kid for attention I mean he'd get
on TV saying that I'd be indicted for
whatever it was but he had no real
knowledge of what was going on he wasn't
actually involved in these things but
like it got him on TV I think that was
part of his own problem and you know
part of so many people's problems right
they do whatever they can for attention
but then finally every once in a while
the dog catches the bus right so he must
have hit on something that got them to
call him in right then you lie about it
I mean that's the reality that's what
they tried doing to me I don't forget
like I did 30 hours of testimony for a
20 minute unsolicited meeting were you
nervous about that not like so like II
even if you know right so you you meet
with these people and you know what the
laws are in your opinion I mean you know
it's on the up-and-up right yeah and
obviously the fact that it wasn't on the
up-and-up they would have gotten you but
when you have to talk about it for
that's why they we need to talk about it
for however many hours yes that's the
point it wasn't that it was anything
you're looking for that one little is
there they're saying well at 12:02 up we
got you it was 12:01 uh you just lied
and then making shadows inconsistency
yes correct they ask you the same
question over and over again and that's
what they try doing and they did it you
know very affect I mean this is well you
know pretty much Adam Schiff that's what
I you know I'd be testifying in front of
you know House Intelligence Committee
and then I'm get done it after nine and
a half hours and I walk outside and I
checked Twitter or whatever it is and
like from 10:00 a.m. you know these
quote-unquote classified 10:00 a.m.
there's literally a play-by-play over
the day now with lies then there's the
leaked emails from it where they take
one of them was about the WikiLeaks
thing which is sort of how the tie and
when they try to tie me with Roger stone
it was like well he had communications
with WikiLeaks I was like well or you
know they're right well here's the date
of it and I go wow that's wait wait a
minute what's wrong with that it's like
well that's four days before it became
public well I was like I didn't get it
four days before it came huh I got it
like six days after or whatever it was
so and it turns out they took the email
and it was like some literally some
random dude and I'd never heard of that
like sent to like 50 emails that were
like some sort of iteration of our
emails and I like he got it right have
you seen the WikiLeaks dump like now but
they took the foot with a one in 14 so
they made you know whatever let's call
it June 14th you eliminate the one in 14
all of a sudden it looks like June 4th
uh-huh right then when you leaked it it
actually became public on the 10th or
the 8th or whatever it was there so it
looked like I had it four or six days
before the rest of the world as opposed
to four or six days after the rest of
the world it was just public information
so they leaked that to CNN huge outrage
cycle oh my god we got them this time
I'm saying I don't know crazy like I'd
it's not accurate but they don't even
print the correction but it lets them
run with a story always dropped on
Friday night so they can get it for the
sunday shows like I was a part of like
four of those outrage cycles like two
of them they did a retraction a couple
of like well we're standing by our
source I'm like this is your source you
admitted it he's on TV saying exactly
the opposite stop like I just want you
to I watched a video I'm sorry to
interrupt you I just watched a video of
a guy from MSNBC trying to get you while
you were having breakfast with your wife
yeah and he's sitting there like and I
mean I was you maintain composure
because it's like you did answer the
question and then just kind of already
hours of testimony you didn't trust me
if these bastards could do something
about it if I did something wrong if
they could do it yeah I ain't getting
them McCabe treatment and that was the
point it was 30 hours not about what I
did but 30 hours to ask me the same
thing hoping that I say something a
little bit different that they could say
out we got it was a perjury trap they
want to see on one inconsistent want me
to make a mistake they say okay that guy
is out there he's loud he's brash you
know we're gonna we're gonna fluster him
over 30 hours mm-hmm we're gonna get him
and then once you know I'm not getting
it like I said McCabe these guys on the
other they literally lied in front of
Congress it is known they didn't even
they didn't even try to do anything to
them there was not even a thought about
punishing them it's a it's different
it's different yeah I would not have
given given that same treatment I'd be
in jail right now what is the like was
there one whether you were nervous was
one of though you were like I said this
different but I didn't mean to it was
like I just said it wrong was there
anything you like I think I you know I
think I played it pretty good like I
think the reality was this I've been you
know sort of you know candidly my own
lawyers were like you got to stop being
so aggressive you got to stop being so
loud whether it was on TV with think
they will take anything you say go it's
different I mean they're telling me like
hey the way to play this legally is it
you just go in there you plead the fifth
that way they can't do anything it's
like I can't do that
what do you mean that's the right legal
move it's like I understand that's what
they need me to do I have to play two
games I have to play the legal game but
I also have to play the PR game I have
to win both the other side only has to
win one okay by winning one they win
both uh-huh and so they're like you know
well you just plead the fifth about this
don't go back in and talk about I go if
I played the fifth there's a presumption
of guilt even if that's not the way the
legal systems supposed to work that is
what mainstream media will run with that
I can't do that because I'm Donald Trump
jr.
I have to go in there and I just have to
pitch a perfect game I got to go in I
got to tell the truth I can't let them
fluster me but it's so even after like
two years of this and millions in legal
fees for [ __ ] you know my own legal
TV honestly you were right like you had
to keep pushing back because the reality
is this if I stop pushing back if i sat
in the corner if I rolled over and
played dead if I cried like a baby like
they would want me to like they would
show me no more mercy they would give me
no quarter they would treat me just as
bad so at least I was able to show you
know their flagrant biases I was able to
call out their [ __ ] I was able to
put forth their lies and even if the
media is not gonna cover it nearly as
much they couldn't run from it entirely
and again I was part of so many of those
outrage cycles you know Michael Cohen
when he went back in and testified I
mean I have 15 people they were like
yeah Michael Cohen with like he
literally lied like I got guys I'll say
no no he lied and everyone knew it but
they're not gonna go after him because
once you flip against Trump you're okay
what are you do you think there's
anything like it's a culture war and
it's like people hate each other's guts
yeah it's not even just politics it's
any side you're on
yeah Twitter and everyone hates each
other is there anything your father can
do that you think would get any portion
of that other side to go you know what I
like you more is there anything you
think at this point that could be done
to turn that a little bit I don't think
so again you saw sort of the the Pelosi
reaction you saw it don't forget again
the Washington Post I keep bringing them
up because you know they would have been
you mean the MS on Washington paramus on
Washington Post but they would have been
a credible thing a couple years ago but
I mean they wrote the article the case
for impeachment right 19 minutes after
the inauguration for 19 minutes when
they wrote that article like you know
this isn't again this isn't box this is
something that you would have said okay
wow that's a credible thing like yeah
that's how crazy it's gotten so you know
the reality is they say they say well
when Trump was campaigning on hey I'm
gonna get NAFTA and renegotiate it for
the American worker that'll never happen
they can't do it it's been there for 25
years no way they never even tried so as
they're pushing the Russia [ __ ] he
actually did it okay as they're signing
the articles for impeachment he signs a
trade deal with China to protect our IP
to
our farmers tree like someone had to
actually be the big boy and like step up
and actually try to do these things
rather than just getting steamrolled for
decades so you would think that someone
reasonable on the other side would be
like okay this is good for us we needed
to do this I may not like the guy I may
not agree with everything he says you
know he's pretty well guess what if they
spent three years basically trying to
impeach you
you know attacking your family trying to
throw your family in jail maybe that
would sort of recenter how aggressive
you are going to approach them and how
civil you're going to be towards them
and no one sort of looks at it through
that window you know but that's the
reality so I'm just psyched to see that
he's actually getting things done and
he's doing it despite resistance I'd
love to see him work on infrastructure
I'd love to see him do these things but
like you literally can't name a single
thing the Democrats have even tried to
move forward even on those things that
they've agreed on the fact he gets no
credit for the economy like that's it's
kind of like they won't get money even
for like the economy being good or
people working and they're like well
well it was trending that way it wasn't
trending that way it was literally a
flatline and then he got rid of
regulations he gave tax reform he did
well how about beyond the economy like
you know how many Democrats are giving
him credit for prison reform you know
this isn't like a Republican party
platform thing Opportunity Zones okay in
those like sort of you know you pour
your urban area it's like that's not a
Republican party platform like you know
rich Republican donors aren't sitting
there been like all we've been waiting
for this one for decades like he just
did it cuz it's the right thing to do
and he's not necessarily bound by sort
of you know conservative dogma or a
leftist Dogma he just does what sort of
right despite that the putting on the
point I was making was that like even
whichever way is going does it matter
because whoever is sitting there gets
either the credit or the blame like so
if it was trending a certain way you
matter like if that if that al baghdadi
thing had gone wrong nobody would have
said hey it was great he was going and
after I'm gonna blame but if Obama got
al-baghdadi they wouldn't call him an
austere religious scholar there'd be
parades in the streets and guess what
when when Obama killed bin Laden
everyone on the right
was like this is great do you mean we
can all recognize this is a win okay you
know no one
you know but to watch the sort of
partisan hackery of oh well it's not
it's not that big a deal or you know
Soleimani from iran you know you have
major generals being like hey you know
whether you like it or not like this guy
was a much more relevant player than you
know bin Laden was at the time of it you
know bin Laden was hiding for the last
ten years it wasn't like this guys
running around the streets organizing
this he's the guy that started the I
Edie sort of program of Iran funded it
that that maimed and killed so many
American soldiers like and to try to be
like all the oh my god it you know how
many times has it been the start of
World War three because of something
Trump's done and many times many to
everyday do you remember he has
breakfast it's the story world where you
move the embassy in Jerusalem op start
of World War three World War three
millions of people were going to die on
that one I remember what happened to
people threw rocks for about three and a
half seconds and it was overly stop
could have been World War three do you
do you remember when Obama made the
announcement about killing bin Laden
do you remember what he interrupted on
television dude it was The Apprentice
the boardroom the boy I remember cuz I
was literally watching The Apprentice
and I was a know what I was happy to
have the interruption it was good a lot
of it comes on now what do you think of
a guy what did you think I guess of a
guy like Andrew yang I love to Andrew
yang for a couple of reasons number one
the stuff he was talking about was I
felt more relevant and different than
the usual talking points of Democrat
Republican whatever politicians but I
also really liked that he and what Dave
Chappelle was saying on his behalf was
that while everybody is sitting there
right and they're trying to say anyone
but Trump Trump is the devil we hate
Trump he's like no let's if you don't
like Trump that's fine let's talk about
the symptoms let's talk about the
country let's move beyond this kind of
individual that everybody's deciding
this is the problem what did you think
of Israel I like I like having people
from outside of the political class you
know I want someone in there whose turn
it wasn't you know I mean III think
that's good I think you saw you know hey
whether you like them or not yeah
there's not an economic metric that you
can't say we're not better off today
than there we were four years ago
you don't have to let Trump you don't
have to agree with how he got there but
like he cut regulations these things
went up if you know if you look at the
lines of
the economy and all these things it was
sort of flatlined for eight years under
Obama literally on November 9th it took
off because you know entrepreneurs small
business big business and they all say
okay we have someone who's not just
gonna try to you know screw us with
excessive regulations and DC and having
people you know take part in them that
have no business you know running your
business or deciding what to do with
your money like so I like an outside I
mean I think sort of the universal bait
I'm gonna give everyone a thousand bucks
a month well guess where it's coming
from
sounds good it's not you know it's not a
government funded program its taxpayer
funded so you know that's sort of a it
sort of screams against everything I
believe in terms of free markets and for
a guy that you know talks a lot about
math you know it this hasn't worked in
other places it's just sort of it's just
but I do like people challenging that
convention you know when you see look at
your Joe Biden who's into the
presumptive nominee and he's been the
presumptive nominee for 18 months in
like um either way so is Jeb that's
precisely the point but like that's the
the discord between the political class
and the elite like I'm looking at Joe
Biden like I don't get it man like every
other day he's like confusing where he
is okay I don't mean like Iowa Ohio I
mean he's in Florida and he's like it's
great to be here in Maine Joe it's uh
it's seven ninety degrees oh maybe
that's like if Donald Trump did that
once right Donald he's got dementia it's
over he's not capable I mean his
dentures were literally falling his
dentures fall out on the debate stage I
believe this guy is the epitome of
health we want this guy to have the
nuclear you think he wanted to I don't
feel like he wanted to ride it no he's
why he wanted to run he was hurt he just
he's never had anyone to actually push
back on him I mean he's been running
since 1988 and never a one do you like
his strategy of being aggressive to
people who don't agree with him Mike
don't like black voters we tell them
just go vote for so you want you to by
just to be tough I go Jill Biden can't
handle one of his supporters asking him
a question how is he gonna do on trip
one-on-one which is am worried that when
challenge him to a push-up contest and
not not so worried race you know so it's
just like I'm looking at this thing I
mean like you know I see Joe Biden
speaking to groups of the massive groups
of 15 to 20 people and they have but
they had him on teleprompter I'm like
dude yeah it's like you know if you
can't win yet
if after 50 years 50 years not hyperbole
50 years as a politician
you can't wing it to 20 people like you
know it doesn't work guys it's not gonna
work like you can hide him right now
when he's in a field of 17 Democrats how
is he gonna do with Trump one on one for
six months not good why do you think cuz
I actually liked Tulsi Gabbard I thought
hey she's my idol Terry why do you think
Hillary came out and yeah what she's so
I mean I decided the only problem I
guess with Tulsi running as a Democrat
is like she sort of feels like a
conservative right like so you know I
imagine that's that which is she's so
far you know away from so many of the
Democrat that she's got Democrat
platforms but if you sort of look at the
history feels like it's evolved into
that as opposed to that's what she
actually is but like she was actually
saying things that make sense which is
so far from so much of the Democrat
platform I mean you know but they'll
Harold Elizabeth Warren like hey
Elizabeth Warren is not someone I'd want
to have the nuclear football okay this
is someone who got trolled into taking a
DNA test and you know that's true
because it was you guys doing that
happened she did she was sitting around
a table gym with her top advisors and
they get the results yeah okay and it
said maybe maybe one 1024 know she got
ten years she got a big gig at Harvard
for a lot of money to teach half a class
for five hundred grand a year
law schools all this stuff her whole
life based on like Native American and
they got back an answer that said you
are less than 1/10 of 1% a Native
American and they sat around that table
and said this is a
like we got them and I'm like this is
not a person that has judgement I want
making decisions for me and my kids I
mean even the anti-trump people were
like holy [ __ ] this is bad this is just
stupid and it's because again if you're
on that side the mainstream media has
decided that they will be your marketing
team they will never never been called
out hmm like so even when the answer was
like no but look oh this is a win she
got to he should yeah like stop I mean
it's literally the same thing as Jeb
doing that commercial where he's running
she's like Pocahontas no no you know
he's actually worse you think so no it's
worse tell me because because she knew
what the answer was and she didn't have
to go public yes she didn't have to go
public she could have been like you know
what maybe I won't push this thing that
much anymore right they have to know
that that was embarrassing you know no
one had to know that she actually took
the test but she took the test got that
answer and was like yes Donald Trump
with this one we won
did you see how stupid that is you saw
her walking she got off a private plane
and like hey look if you got to travel
you're a candidate just say you're doing
it of course but then she's trying to
duck behind somebody cuz there's so and
you pretend you're not getting a picture
of me coming off at this private plane
like I get it like hey I have this too I
mean when I campaign I I've done days
where I've done nine stops you can't do
that commercial right you can't do that
commercially now if I'm doing
fundraisers or whatever it is fine I can
fly Kimora like commercial all the time
I fly commercial coach all the time it
doesn't matter to me but like it means I
can do to actual stops cuz that's the
reality right I mean I can go on a
privately I can land and thing I can get
off the plane and do a rally at a hangar
you know raise whatever money we're
raising and get to the next one and
understanding there's a there's a
greater cost but you know the cost of
the private travel is is outweighed by
the fact that hey I can do nine events
that are more than paying for this
therefore I am net ahead therefore it
makes sense but it is ironic when
they're screaming and you know all the
people in Hollywood like guess what when
you go to the Oscars or you travel to
New York for an award show like that's
one trip like you don't need to fly
private you don't need to go in your own
plant but they all do they do it
you scream at regular people for you
know having a you know a car that has
you know an extra cubic inch you know of
engine capacity and they're terrible
people like stop guys you're full of
[ __ ] do you think cuz it's interesting
how there's this business thing with
your dad and Greta foon Berg and she's
17 I think I'm saying her name right is
is does he dislike her or it goes nicely
over and he spoke nicely ever at
something I saw recently is like I would
love to have heard her speak like
there's no thing with her the media
tries to create a thing with her but the
reality is it's like no he did imply
that she doesn't seem like she likes to
have a fun I don't think she does I
don't I don't think you know but like
you have someone who they've said you
know has you know these like learning
disabilities and you could see like this
is just someone that they put for their
like we got it was sort of like it was
like Muller right they picked someone
that oh this person's above reproach you
can't go after her we're gonna give her
sound bikes like once you make yourself
a political person like you then can't
oh you can't attack that person she's 17
in autistic or whatever is that she is
like well guys like your spoon feeding
her these lines you're traveling her all
over the world every left isn't the
world's like all we got to get behind it
was like robert muller they picked rub
robert muller he's beyond reproach he
was the head of the FBI he was a guy
that was it was a war veteran trump
can't attack him then you see him
testifying you're like oh a [ __ ] did
this guy even read the report like he
was just a pawn he was put in there
because like it's just all marketing and
that's the scam that people are sick of
i mean you know the fact that like you
know greta Sundberg you know with with
the notes that people put in front of
her and a soap box that the media has
built up becomes like TIME's Person of
the Year and not the people that are
literally protesting the communist
regime in Hong Kong risking their lives
taking on the Chinese government like
you know they get like an honorable
mention somewhere I do like that she's a
teenager doing something I never does
complain about teenager hundred-percent
but like again is it her or is it a well
choreographed marketing machine using
her you know I'm gonna guess the
combination I'm gonna go so sincere but
I do believe that as she's gotten more
and more famous people
like oh let's see if we can get her you
know let's try to get our narrative but
I think she's probably just as you know
typical teenager she believes something
really strongly
I love teenagers to get more involved
and you see that it but like you know
the reality is like teenagers today are
sort of blindly taking the points that
are being spoon-fed to them by like
leftist academia and just like running
with it like the only kids that are
actually brave today are like
conservatives on college campuses
because they're not just you know
they're making up their own minds
they're not just being indoctrinated
have you done like interviews of people
because it's always we're when you meet
someone face to face like it's always an
odd thing like I've attacked people and
then met them I was like oh I'm a dick
have you met people who've attacked you
and then done interviews with them and
at the end you're like you know what
that person is actually okay and I
actually you know surprisingly enough
and you know I understand we're on
different sides or whatever it is like I
actually have pretty decent relationship
she's in like mainstream media you know
with people that are definitely not on
my side that definitely sort of you know
take you know a lot of shots at us but I
think you know there's still
relationships there and I think because
of that and you know I'm I'm pretty open
and honest like there's a reason hey not
a lot of guys in my position are coming
on this show like I'd be doing oh na
with you guys wait four years actually
zero guys of your position Josh yeah
I'll take those chances I really you
know there's not a lot of upside it's
not like I'm getting people onto my side
by doing it and frankly you know [ __ ]
from the O&A days you know there were
things that would come Donald Trump jr.
said this I'm like well it's you know
like they don't put it in the content
they make it seem like I get I said this
at the State of the Union as opposed to
like I said it while like literally
promoting a reality show on a comedy
show on a comedy show where like yes I
get it I know I'm not allowed to have a
personality or say something but they
run with it as though it's castable so
you know but though there are people
that you know there's just not that many
of them and there's so many there's so
many people you think you have that
relationship with in media it's like
okay way I'll talk off the record you
know I've never lied to you yada yada
yada and then they sort of take that and
betray that trust
you know that's happened a lot to me
yeah and so it does make you put your
guard up with people that you did
otherwise perhaps have a decent
relationship with and whatever and I
just again I don't feel that trust is
betrayed on the other side it's only
like bow because we can get Trump it's
worth it who do you think
is the fairest person or the most honest
person that clearly doesn't like you
like in the press I mean like like is
there a guy that even though he might
get it wrong okay you don't think he has
integrity there's a couple and the only
problem is if I say that it cuz and I I
don't want to give the name because I've
seen that like I've gotten you know
whether it's you know a couple times you
know whether it's the Washington Post
New York Times like they write even a
reasonable article on me meaning you
know I'm not you know I'm a zing Li
enough I am NOT actually you know a
neo-nazi white nationalist like whatever
and it's like you watch them get
canceled by their own people just for
being objective or not are saying hey
you know someone wrote an article about
me when a New York Times wrote an
article about me but in like sort of my
social media presence and how it sort of
become of you know at least on our side
a pretty big phenomenon and I was one of
the most impression probably
conservatives even as a non-politician
other than my father and it's like sort
of came out of nowhere so they were it
was you know somewhat complementary in
the sense but it wasn't anything that
wasn't demonstrably accurate based on
you know measurable Metris ease right
and it was like they get destroyed so
it's sort of fun I don't even want to
give their names because then if you
have a relationship that you can utilize
to say hey this is what actually
happened as opposed to this and maybe
they give you a little bit of the
benefit that doubt because you've never
lied to him if I actually out make sure
funding for them yeah they literally
almost have to go harder just to not get
canceled by their own following
did you get a be honest as you always
are a quick hot flash of embarrassment
when you're going through your Twitter
account and you read that your dad
congratulated the great state of Kansas
on their Super Bowl with like the
reality like Donald Trump doesn't
pretend to not be real so it doesn't
matter I mean I like it I think Donald
Trump if you know him and you know I
think he's probably done plenty of this
like he is able to joke about those kind
of things he is able to sort of you know
own a mistake you know he's the guy that
you want to kind of have a beer with
because you know you're gonna get
something interesting it's not here are
the talking points I will read them to
you and they have you know it's it's
different than a Mike Bloomberg who in
his life consider because he's a guy he
doesn't seem like he gets bossed around
by anybody
who in his life can say to him don't ya
know when to reach out to him and go
like it's not Kansas yeah it's not like
who do you think is coming I think any
any one of us you know the kids or
whatever
obviously if Uncas there and in the
Edmond she could probably do that but
like I can call me but hey by the way
and he really he would literally laugh
and let Billy that way you know it's not
like push him back on it let's do it you
know like I think he'll just own those
mistakes I don't think he pretends to be
perfect that way I didn't know a
president could do I thought there was a
thing that they couldn't delete tweets
and then they do leave that one way all
I guess you can I didn't know that they
I thought there was like the record has
to be no the Internet is forever right
that's what you see all these people
that are you know that now you go back I
mean that's how they got that Roger
stone juror they go back on the Twitter
feed him yeah how did this person pass
any sort of reasonable screening like
this is a person that ran for Congress
that was vehemently anti Trump literally
on the jury of a guy that you know the
media is heralding as this you know
Trump you know supporter even if he
didn't have that much of a role like
stop like what do you what do you think
because like when your dad ran and I'm
sure this would be part of him running
again the whole point is still
anti-establishment we've been talking
about it the whole time like from
separated whatever the fact that now I
feel like every time you open your mouth
there's somebody that talks about you
becoming the President of the United
States of America people are chanting it
when you're at one of these rallies you
were talking about they're talking about
it on the TV shows you go to the idea
that what was this sort of outsider
revolution regime thing is is could be a
dynasty and there are people who are
supporting the idea that after 2020
going into 2024 should your dad be
successful or who knows maybe should he
not be successful you just wait for
years or maybe they run in 2020 you've
seen the way this works out right you've
seen four years of it or so is that
something that you could see in your
future down the road looking past 2020
listen you know I've enjoyed the game I
seems like you do I know that was I I
liked it like you know when they start
hey I'm not gonna lie right it's sort of
cool if you're in a stadium of 15,000
people and they start chanting 46 when
you're speaking it's like now listen my
only focus is getting my father really
liked it because I believe he's doing
the right things for America I get I
like the fight I think you know for for
better or worse I got that sort of Trump
gene that could handle sort of that
pressure aspect that doesn't bother me
if people are pushing back and writing
bad that like I just I'm not that fazed
by it yeah I don't know that I'd like
the day job and that's a big part of it
right you know campaign you know I got
to make sure I would want that in time
so you know it's it's an honor I mean
it's you know I can't I can't say that
doesn't feel good but you know I I don't
I have no plans for it right now
you know people are always like oh he's
running I got no no I just can't say no
because in this day and age if I say
yeah no I'm not gonna do that
Oh 12 years later a liar 12 years ago
you went on Jim Norton and Sam Roberts
you said you were there for you know I
just I don't want to be that guy but
like listen I see the results man I you
know and again whether it's my hobbies
are you hunting fishing shooting all the
stuff AG I I have seen middle America
and it wasn't like I just magically
appeared there you know once we got into
politics like I have friends all over
the place there because that's sort of
where I spend my free time I'm actually
probably much more comfortable there
than I am in New York City IQ don't see
me on like the you know the New York
City sword like BS like rubber chicken
you know charity dinner [ __ ] circuit
like you know where everyone just goes
kisses their own asses it's like it's
not me it never has been so you know I
think I get it and so when I go around
those places and I see the results and I
see these people I said it last night
like you see like a grown man that come
up like hey like I was able to start
this business because of these policies
because of what see a grown man in tears
talking about this or like man and in
New Hampshire was sort of interesting is
as I go just by chance like in between
stops where I was going this like thank
people who are working on our teams to
be like okay let's go to this coffee
shop we just gotta you know get some
caffee and I don't want to be called
low-energy jib you go in there we went
into one got another one still a Trump
guys come on
you know go into this coffee shop and
you know 23 year old female you know it
just got out of like culinary school and
like she literally started her own
business she's got this great coffee
shop and I'm like this okay you know
coffee shop you know female young like
this is not I love what you guys are
doing thank you so much for like making
this possible for me in this town which
I never thought like man it's awesome
right Lord it feels it really feels good
it's so you know like I said my father
didn't need this job but you know the
fact that he's getting the results that
he's had you know what and again you
know it's not like what the media tries
to portray and I mean you saw that there
they're literally doing you know talks
in the DNC to try to be able to come up
with ways that they can talk to their
constituents to tell them the economy is
not that good like guys when you're
doing that it means you've lost this
issue is not you know that they're
trying to figure out ways to make it not
as good as it actually is like that's
pretty sick but like that's the reality
man it is good and people are benefiting
it from it and you and it's not just
your billionaires with stock portfolios
like how's your 401k doing how's your
401k doing like yeah you know the
regulations that have done this all time
blow unemployment numbers for African
Americans all-time high startup numbers
for female businesses for
african-american businesses for Hispanic
businesses like like when I see him at
the State of the Union he says those
things and the Congressional Black
Caucus refuses to stand or clap like is
that not something like are we that far
deranged is Trump derangement syndrome
like that far set in that we can't all
acknowledge that that is a good thing
whether you like you know the guy that
implemented the policies that got that
to happen like if Obama did that they'd
anoint him Emperor for life
they'd be talking about it all day long
and it's like I know Trump they're just
not gonna we're gonna pretend that that
didn't happen who arranged is the
seating at that okay that is an issue
stops eating all the conservatives and
all the lipid like if they just mixed
everybody up it would just be so awkward
you got a buddy like you control your
neighbor
mix it up they should mix it up a little
bit because it's just - it's the
insincerity of all the politicians
standing to agree or not it's almost
like if you don't buy any of it it's a
good press gave your dad any credit for
the good things he's done which the
economy is great people are worried then
people might listen a little more when
they said something negative but I don't
listen to any of the stuff because they
don't give them any credit for the good
by the way I agree it's sort of like
what we talked about with the racism
when you hear this say it's like the boy
who cried wolf right when you hear the
same thing over like you start sort of
ignoring it yeah so so their hits and
hey some of them maybe found it some of
them may action but like when it's so
far and so extreme and like you take
what was once a rational thought and you
morph it so like vision like you're like
come on come on like stop you know I
think the media themselves have really
no one's done more to discredit the
media than the media itself and so you
know they've stopped having you know
that effect but the fact that they
literally can't give Donald Trump credit
for anything like III think that real
people see through it man I think that
they get it now again it's still a
powerful force you had a multi-billion
dollar mainstream media complex who says
96% negative things about Trump and yet
you still have those sort of records
like I don't know for a guy like me who
lives it every day like I see through it
but like for the guy that's consuming
five minutes of news a day I don't know
maybe he doesn't maybe he's actually
still blinded by that so I imagine that
sort of their game plan to try it up you
know to try to screw them over you know
over the next ten months and honestly
there's probably gonna have that there's
probably some effect of that that we
have to overcome like you don't get that
same attacks from you know I use the you
know the Biden example with hunter Biden
like Joe you know do you think Jim that
the media would have a problem if Donald
Trump jr. was over in the Ukraine right
now sitting on a board of a Ukrainian
oil company making 83 grand a month I
think they'd be very fair about it thank
you for your honesty Jim Norton like
they won't cancel you for me
like go crazy I kind of I thought I was
watching the news I thought you already
were by the way that's why say like you
know in the book I talk about I go like
the reality is this like when I used to
come on this show like we were actually
international business people right
that's what we did that was a big part
of what I did and when my father won we
said fight we will not do new deals
going forward now if we have an asset
abroad like you can't just right dump it
you can't just sell it or if you're in
the middle of building a building but we
said hey from this day forward we will
not do new deals and we have it and we
have it and the media out there
enriching themselves abroad I'm like but
you're really silent about the other
side you're really silent about you know
hunter Biden making millions from a
Ukraine he doesn't speak Ukrainian and
he doesn't know anything about energy
like why is he there I mean he did that
ABC interview do you see that one like
where they had weeks to prep it and
choreograph it like Joe did or uh hunter
you know and they're like well so why
were you there he's like oh man like he
didn't even think he was gonna be asked
the question you have no tolerance for
because you did you're 30 I've been
pretty vicious yeah against him but like
I sort of feel like I don't know guys
like this guy's the start of the Ukraine
problem and you know we don't need to
hear from him like there's nothing okay
unsolicited meeting by the way paid for
by the DNC no one even talks about that
right yeah set up and paid for by the
DNC because I'd looked at a deal when we
were international business people so I
said yeah that's your business got you
take a meeting right what we do right so
that's a problem that merits 30 hours of
testimony put him while his father's on
tape saying if you don't stop
investigating my son's company that he's
on the board of and making millions from
I'm gonna do pull billions in aid from
you oh yes
that's totally legit so yeah I take it a
little bit more personally because I've
been the recipient right of how vicious
it is I've been the recipient of that
hatred of that mainstream media complex
so when I see them doing nothing I'm
like Oh guys doesn't seem fair because
I'm I don't care like if you want to
play hardball play hard
all right if you want to play softball
play softball but we got to be playing
the same game but we're not sistent a
double standard is so flagrant it's
disgusting and so I will spend a lot of
time highlighting it do you guys ever
panic a little bit when when Rudy
Guiliani but dials oh my god what are
you doing if it happens to all of us but
these are like high-level conversations
yeah I like Rudy have a lot of respect
for you is a great guy be there but
that's the problem with some of this
world right like even when I was going
through my that like really wasn't be a
part of my legal team they're separate
and whatever and they'd ask him a
question about my things so he'd sort of
given off-the-cuff answer but he may not
have actually known the details I'm like
that's wrong crap now I got to fix this
yeah but like sort of expected to give
an answer to the sanity say I don't know
it's like what's the diameter of the Sun
well it's this just say I'm not his
lawyer I I don't speak for i but yeah
again but you sort of part of other
things and so I yeah people make that
mistake and that's you know and then the
media gets to seize on that so you know
yeah I don't like any of that game you
know I wish but I wish the game was such
that it was based on actual fact it's
based on an objective standard but it's
not and so you just sort of have to play
you know it's like hey I get that the
rules are skewed against me and us and I
just got to play that game that's fine
and we're gonna just fight harder and
that's why you know Trump's the unique
phenomenon he doesn't just roll over and
die because the other side wants him to
now you know Jeb would have 17
Republican candidates during my father's
primary who would have stuck with
Cavanaugh
right who know just name name one person
who would have been like you know what
I'm going all in to say that you know
when the left is there and you have
Blasi forward he's getting waiting also
to what you know you don't remember when
you don't remember the year you don't
remember how but you knew he was a
serial gang rapists and he magically
made it to you know the Court of Appeals
and he's like stop but isn't it weird
that no one would have stuck with I put
the over-under at one second before
everyone else fold and by the way if
they would have folded it doesn't just
mean he's not on the Supreme Court yeah
it means you destroyed his career you
destroyed his life you destroyed his
family and and I think that's sort of
the point is there is nothing just like
the you know the Covington kids there's
nothing that the leftists like you know
they're in in DC there's nothing that
they hold sacred there's nothing or no
one that they wouldn't destroy to try to
further their political ideology and I
know and that's sad that that's a that's
a sick place we're in but like we're
just gonna destroy this guy and like hey
man whether you like him or not with you
they Trump stuck by him and that's not
easy and there were plenty of
conservatives saying hey like okay it's
time to pull the ripcord on this one
he's like I can't do that Trump III
think that your dad might have a similar
thing about people that he perceives her
against him that I don't think that
there's much sacred ground that your dad
wouldn't trample over if he said this is
somebody who's against me I don't care
who it is I mean we were just talking
about the fact that he's the one guy who
doesn't a child's life to try to put
forth his agenda that's not what it's
not you know he'll go after the
individual uh-huh he'll go after the
individual and like hey like like I said
how come why was it me how come I was
the guy that needed to start calling out
hunter bided how come like it would be
nice if there was a business let's call
it in industry whose job it was to look
into these things and to report to
people what's going on in the world it
would be nice if they're worried about
news media nice if that existed I see
how come I'm the guy that has to be like
hey guys uh I'm gonna look at this and
call [ __ ] there were moments where
it looked like
he was gonna get a like there was times
we would have like these dinners really
I think I breakfast with Zucker showed
up and it looked like he was gonna like
that relationship was gonna get fixed
and then it just falls apart of it
problems even with like something like a
facebooking again I I've been one of the
guys sort of you know really pushing
sort of the the censorship issue in
these things where they're trying to
have it both ways a lot of Republicans
frankly you didn't even realize this is
an issue with you know their base where
they're like what do you mean I you know
if you're a second Amendment guy if
you're you know you sort of devoutly
religious like you know these people are
getting shadow band and demonetised ad
platforms and all of these like it's a
real thing but you notice like you've
never heard one person on the left ever
[ __ ] about being like D platform's on a
social regardless of how extreme what
they say but like you know I like guns
up that's over you know all of your
following is in half the next day you
know so I've been one of those people
you know to call out those things and
the problem is this when you have an
even if Zuckerberg was going to try to
be objective I don't think he is I think
he sort of believes most of that side
but even if he wanted to be a little bit
impartial you know the problem is they
have like seventy five thousand
employees that are you know literally
the epitome of you know woke culture you
know I don't even know what that means
because it changes every day Jim as you
know and you know what's woke today is
like tomorrow it's all right right
there's the goalposts never stop moving
the landmines that just keep getting
tossed out as you're walking yeah well
throw it like what would have been it's
funny though that it's or either one or
the other two it's like well if it's not
woke then it's alright yeah pick one two
bins yeah if I don't like you you're a
Nazi like wow that's gonna be really
awkward like Jared's an Orthodox Jew my
sister is orthodontic Thanksgiving is
gonna be really awkward guys I like you
but we got a little problem we gonna
stop yeah stop it again everything is so
extreme there's not like I disagree with
them policy it becomes the personal hit
and I I get it we are guilty over that
too I be biggest hypocrite in the world
but like I got a play you know in in on
the battlefield that I'm given and I'll
play you know I'm not afraid of that
that's you know again that's why I'm
here because I'm not afraid to you know
put myself out there a little bit
understanding that there's you know
probably no upside and there's only
downside right but I do it anyway and
it's
sort of like what why my father did what
he's doing he got that there's no up
there's no upside as a business guy to
go do this and to say what needs to be
said and piss off half of the country
like there's no but like sometimes you
just got a man up and be like or you
know woman up sorry cuz otherwise I'm a
misogynist enough personnel yes person
who identifies as a person a person yes
person up yes and you know and do what
needs to be done it does help you though
it does how be gain that base that when
when there is that part a lot of times
when you get half the country to hate
you at the same time you're getting half
the country to love you you know what I
mean I think that being so combative is
what has built your guys thanks I think
without question at least partially but
it I think that's more because of the
nature of that right it's no secret that
the media has been left-leaning for a
long time now I think it's gone haywire
right it's gone it's gone so much
further than that but like I think the
people on our side they've had they've
watched for decades while they get
trampled for turning the other cheek the
other side you know we're gonna be nice
we're gonna be reasonable we're gonna be
loose and we're gonna break and lose age
and it's like I think they got sick of
that so they were like wait a minute
like someone's gonna actually push back
on [ __ ] like someone's actually like
whoa what I can get behind this because
I'm sick of turning the other cheek and
losing each and every time even if we
feel that we're right and you know I
think that's what gave you Trump well
even on CNN like this was like it's
unnecessary edits like I think it was in
Japan and there was something where they
were dumping food and fish and they made
it look like oh look at this clown he
did it the wrong way
he didn't take a pinch but what they
don't show is five seconds before the
Prime Minister of Japan a Bey literally
dumps his thing yes so Trump does what
the Prime Minister of Japan does and
they're like oh he should have been like
stop but and then they get caught and
then it's like oh oh just stop trying to
make everything and own you know when
you're trying so hard to own him with
each and everything that he does like it
loses its efficacy right just wait for
it wait for it take your spot he'll make
a mistake oh yeah and then you can
pounce but like I gave him some credit
when he doesn't like
you could actually have a real own as
opposed to like having to do the
retraction or having to have you know
all of social media like pounced on you
and you know call you out for your BS
and watch your ratings go because you've
made a political decision to be the anti
trunk network as opposed to a news
network it is crazy how they keep saying
he's ruining to me but all he's doing is
pointing out stuff but he's like well
all he's doing is pointing out what I've
always hated about them Italy and they
just can't stop do it it's almost like
now it's a it's a contest and they can't
stop doing it no I listen I'd sort of
joked the other day and I think it was
true like Donald Trump's superpower is
getting other people to expose you know
their insanity yeah you know he sort of
does his thing but drives them crazy and
said the other day yeah one thing that
he does better than anybody else is
bring out the worst in people that's the
first thing I thought when I saw Pelosi
ripping up the speech I'm like whether
you whoever side you're on here you're
supposed to be the one that we look to
because you're calling out the president
for doing stuff like that once you do
stuff like that
you've become a hypocrite but but okay
fine so I think we're we're in agreement
whether it is politically or not but
like in this instance we're in agreement
and you know you're not exactly a right
wing you know all right guy Jim right
like we're in agreement that that was
the wrong move right by Nancy Pelosi
yeah who called her out of media I mean
she was good I heard I heard her call
the hero stop but that individual no
thinking being you know was thinking
that like that's wonderful
she'd like she did like some sort of
focus group to be like how can I get the
most attention on media these days and
the media went for it hook line & sinker
no one said hey it's totally
inappropriate like they tried saying
well Trump didn't shake her hand I'm
like I'm looking at the video like he
didn't shake my pants his hand either he
handed the things over and was turning
around she extended his hand as he's
looking like 90 degrees away may not
have even seen it and they're like well
that's that's the snub to justify it I'm
like stop conquer the house to hard the
Speaker of the House ripping up the
President's speech and if it was a bomb
as a president the Conservatives did
let's say the same if it was a member
see when he's looking for a job
okay if this was John Boehner to Obama
back in the day and he ripped up the
speech they throw him out of office for
ripping up a federal document if Donald
Trump did this they'd say up we're gonna
impeach him for ripping up a piece of
paper because it's a federal document
like and again I think that's the double
standard that so many people are sick of
honestly even even some people on the
Left they're like you know we're
shooting ourselves like the James
Carville's of the world who are yo rabid
leftist but I like James Caan he's a
rabid leftist but I'm like he's like we
are insane stop being insane I mean even
you know Bill Mark you know had banging
on these days like yeah you're right
where we are showing the worst of us and
you know is this violent like I don't
worry with him on any of these things
but like I appreciate that someone can
recognize where where they're wrong just
like I think I can do it with us
sometimes you know I mean I'm like I
know when you've taken sort of the hitch
that I take and the family takes and you
take it a little bit more personal it's
like yeah I'm gonna be a little more
aggressive than I would be otherwise but
like in my mind I've earned that right
Bill Maher's a liberal guy who I like
because he doesn't languish police
people are just tired of being scolded
that's the main thing like people are
sick and tired of being scolded for
every mistake every missing someone in
the mainstream eight will write an
article that I cursed today I hope they
note that I didn't care for it you have
chastised me greatly yeah you know
somebody as opposed to understanding
that there are different contexts for
different things and like you know I I
try to pride myself on at least being a
real even if you know we live in a sort
of a did you everything that you would
get to be an adult and then there would
be somebody who wanted to write a
newspaper article that you use the
f-word
we're not adults
the reality is like there are no adults
in the room anymore you know we've sort
of we've we've long overshot that you
know and you see it every day
this is everything you like for them now
you're like okay this has happened this
to your husband for the rest of your
life this is gonna be something you have
to dislike you weren't famous before but
does it ever like sit sit with you like
god this is gonna be the next 40
I'm gonna have to yeah it's a it's a
little different and I hey just with my
hobbies and things like there's
something nice about anonymity you know
what I mean like and even with the
apprentice like if I showed up in a suit
people like wait a minute like now it's
like I could be wearing a hat in like a
t-shirt and they're like serious you
know remember that special voice it
depends on the hat yeah you can some
hats that is true do you disguise
whether I'm fooling around trying to go
incognito but it doesn't change things
all that much for me these days so you
know I I miss a little bit of that
anonymity
but you know it in the end I think it's
worth it cuz I like what's going on
listen I'm the father of five young kids
I sort of see that the push towards
crazy I I think of so many of those
things is you're so anti-american
whether it's the attack on the Second
Amendment
[ __ ] the attack on the First Amendment
now you can't say these things you you
know did you're a comedian I mean look
at like just a canceled culture in
comedy like it's it's sick I mean I love
what Chappelle did you know a couple
weeks ago but like the fact that he's
one of the few people brave enough to
actually even take on the subject I'm
like you guys realize like this is your
livelihood like you're not allowed to be
funny because the problem with being
funny and I'm not a comedian I'm not
that funny I just say sort of what I'm
thinking a lot like the problem with
being funny is to be good it's no
different than anything else that's no
different than being an entrepreneur
you're gonna have some fails a lot of
families have some wits and today if
you're in comedy and you have a whiff
and it may not be that it's not funny
but it's just not funny to that guy yeah
right now that one guy doesn't think
it's funny because you made some sort of
joke about you know you know trans
female weightlifters you know destroying
the competition like or it's over
yeah life is over so you don't take
those risks anymore you don't take that
chance
hell they come after but he's great
because I give a [ __ ] he doesn't give a
[ __ ] he saw like he just lets people say
what they want cuz he takes any side
it's like Chris Rock's another one who's
great and like I don't always know what
side he's gonna take and that's to me
what I like about a comedian like like
him or like charelle you don't always
know where they're gonna come down like
what side they're gonna come down on
correct but then also I mean then the
part and now this is where I'm gonna
contradict my last day that you have
sort of the you have the comedians that
then
try to become political activists and
it's now now they're no longer being
funny and they can do stuff that is vile
and try to use it under the guise of
comedy when everyone reasonably realizes
they're not being comedians so it's like
well we can say whatever we want because
I was once a comedian like no you're not
you're a you're an activist now you know
so you it's it's hard I mean it's a fine
line if you're attempting to be like
following a these guys who are activists
who are comedians and they believe
politically and they're very funny even
if I don't agree with them they're still
good yeah but you got to try to be funny
first and make your point while you're
being funny like no one wants you to
stop onstage and sit there and priest
it's embarrassing no one gives a [ __ ]
clap that's what politicians are for so
yeah I mean I'm it's got to be rough I
mean exactly listen I've seen your stuff
for years like you know there there are
things in some of the great comedy stuff
of all I mean takes repelling Chappelle
show is literally some of the best TV
ever made
there are skits that are incredible that
I literally cannot even joke about today
yeah you know I mean what he did Clayton
Bigsby like come on man it's easy you
can't say he's the opening sketch on the
show and you're just like it was
probably the funniest you know four
minutes of TV history because he's and
he's calling up and you know it's comedy
today it'd be oh you couldn't do that
it's good you couldn't do that it you
can go get e Murphy raw you know there's
someone that stand up you're even a TV
there was a movie today you couldn't say
the things that he you can go to network
TV you gotta look at and not even that
long ago you can look at I don't know
you never watch it Jim but the first
season of the office that was on NBC in
primetime if you go back and you watch
it on Netflix you're like never never it
wouldn't fly even jokes they would do on
panel on The Tonight Show like I was
watching some old Dangerfield stuff and
I'm like there's a couple things where
even I was like but it was like still it
was like 1983 and the things that they
did today would get you ruined even if
you did them on HBO or Netflix correct I
mean I think South Park still take some
of these they do yeah you know and they
don't give a [ __ ] they've been told it
like their involvement in the car to it
like they're above it all like you know
Family Guy used to be great and even
it's gone like or you could just see us
like
leftist messaging you know it's just
lost its lost the comedy appeal and just
tries to go for like a kill shot each
and every time so you know it's a shame
to see it then you know and it's someone
who's you know Saturday Night Live you
know I used to as a kid like I'd watch
the reruns of you know once of Saturday
Night Live my whole life it was awesome
and it's like today it's like okay here
we go like you kind of know what I don't
like to know where they're coming from
politically like I don't care if they
like Obama but I didn't need them to
sing you know to Sir with love or
whatever the song I'll get some they're
waiting for a punchline when you know
what the punchline is before it's ever
delivered half the time the surprise of
where it goes yeah it is is part comic
can't have a point of view of course you
can but like when it's the same one
every time and you're not trying to be
funny you're trying to prove it to me
that's it you don't need to do that just
but there's liberal comedians I think
are brilliant I don't give a [ __ ] about
me laughs of course I guess we have to
end our show it's it's really we usually
end at 9:50 and it's now 10:20 I know we
were supposed to end at 9:40 - no one
told us no no no no not for I mean we
that's when the show could have ended
cuz we didn't take a break oh you think
a break yeah like I said I'll have the
conversation by the way there will be
numerous articles canceling me over the
coming days that's where we're banking
on and I don't give a [ __ ] yeah I just
don't and there will be an article about
me saying that and saying that I don't
give a [ __ ] and so on and so forth and
we will get yelled at because when you
walked in we didn't throw water bottles
at you scream at you like there's no
winning for those of you who are what
Jim just punched me in the face and and
kicked me and called me all right off
off camera just to save you the hassle
and I threw my shoe at at him while he
was on the I want you to go into the
weekend with that kind of hate for just
having a conversation as opposed to for
just trying to cancel me and by the way
how great would it be if the Secret
Service is just listening to this and
has no vision
just got shot buckwheat has been shot
Thank You doc it's good see you know
you're welcome back anytime you want to
command it to do it we will uh see you
guys uh Monday yes or Tuesday bra we'll
see you next week
you see you next week